So now I can run my app but
it's probably not going to work
because I haven't set up the API key.
The next thing that you should do
is to go to the Google console and
then based on the name of the app,
like in this case you can see
my app is at
com.google.devplat.lmoroney.maps3_2.
I need to set that up
within the API console.
So if you remember in
the earlier lesson,
when we created public API access,
we had an API key and
we had Android applications that
were allowed to use that API key and
these were defined by the SHA 1,
in this case the debug one.
Followed by a semi-colon,
followed by the name of the application.
Now you can see here I've done
the same thing, the same SHA 1.
And now this application,
com.google.devplat.lmoroney.maps3_2.
This is the most common place you go
wrong in writing applications and
creating them.
Is that either you've named this
incorrectly, you've made a mistake
with the SHA 1 key, your API key is
wrong or something along those lines.
So if you this API key beginning
with Alza and ending with d or
z8, if I go back to Android Studio and
go to my Android manifest,
you can see I have, it was Aiza.
Sorry, not Alza.
You can see I have the API key set up
here correctly and it's definitely
the same name application
com.google.devplat.lmaroney.maps3_2.
A little pro tip is if you ever
refactor it, and you'll think you've
refactored and you've gotten everything
changed if you refactor the name of your
package and you'll find that
maps don't actually work.
What can happen is that
while your refactor it and
while you've changed it on the console
in refactoring in buildup Gradle
the application id string
here may not change.
So if you ever refactor your app and
find trouble, just make sure to
come back into your buildup Gradle and
make sure that the string here with
an application ID matches
the refactoring that you've done.
So let's now run the application and
take a look.
And here it is again.
Here's the application running.
You can see I'm centered
on New York City.
I have my three buttons
laid out across the top.
Remember, that was
the horizontal layout.
And then the entire thing is in a
vertical layout with the button panel on
top of the actual map fragment and
of course I can continue to pan and
zoom around the map if I so desire.
And when I press the buttons,
for example the hybrid button,
I now get a hybrid map, which you'll
see more closely if I zoom in, so
you can see the street
names were highlighted and
the streets themselves were highlighted.
And when I press the buttons for
example, the hybrid button,
I now get a hybrid map, which you'll
see more closely if I zoom in.
So I have the satellite
photographic map,
but with the lines of roads and things
laid out on top of it, which is really,
really useful when you're
navigating around places.
Or if I just want the pure
satellite picture, here it is.
So it was as simple as that.
Very little coding and you're beginning
to see that you can build some pretty
powerful functionality.